f you want to see a prototypical example of
bottom of the barrel, counterproductive, dangerous,
backwards ignorance and weaponized thinking
look no further than at what happened in Idaho
over the weekend on the steps of the Idaho
State Capitol in Boise, Idaho, parents and
their children staged an anti mass protest
where they had a fire going in a barrel and
they angrily threw surgical and other types
of masks into the barrel in what I guess was
supposed to be some kind of defiant and principled
statement about not being forced to wear masks
or not believing in the pandemic or about
being angry that there are covid guidelines.
And this is obviously bad enough at the surface
level, the idea that wearing masks to be part
of keeping people safe and reducing the spread
would make anybody angry.
That's that's bad.
That's a problem.
But also, on a very practical level, many
masks include plastic fibers and other things
that you don't want to be burning and breathing
in.
And yet parents and their children are encouraged
by their parents, are participating gleefully
and breathing in the smoke from the masks.
It's all insane protesting guidelines meant
to stop the spread of a respiratory virus
by breathing in harmful fumes from burning
masks.
You can't write the stuff you really can't.
And adding to the absurdity is that Idaho
doesn't even have a state mask mandate.
You're they don't have what you would typically
protest at the state capital when the governor
or the state legislature is doing something
you don't like, Idaho has no Marzook mandate.
Why are they protesting at all?
Never mind, at the Capitol?
Well, visitors to the Capitol building specifically
are asked to wear masks.
It's not even required or enforced.
Republicans introduced a bill last week to
ban mask mandates in Idaho.
Republican Governor of Idaho Brad Little has
never issued a statewide mask mandate.
There are some individual counties.
There are some cities that have mask mandates.
Maybe they should be protesting there instead
of at the state capitol, but really they shouldn't
be protesting at all.
I may be trying to apply logic to a situation
where clearly there is no logic and the involvement
of children in this makes it extra disgusting.
Like what are you teaching them here while
you have them breathe in the fumes of burning
masks?
You teach them to disrespect government buildings
by making a fire on the front steps of one
playing with fire, irresponsible mask behavior
because, of course, while burning the masks,
they're not wearing masks.
I mean, kids and adults grabbing fistfuls
of masks during a pandemic and burning them.
You're really not these aren't children that
you're you're setting up for upper management,
let's put it that way.
Now, how would this be different?
If instead of going to a mass burning, they
went to one of the refrigerated morgue trucks
that some hospitals have parked outside because
they don't have enough room inside the hospital
for the dead bodies of people that died of
covid, or you go to some places where they're
holding memorials for the people that died
official, officially 500 and 25000 Americans
dead.
If you estimate the uncounted deaths could
be more like 680 or 700000 covid deaths.
But in Idaho, they're not going to look at
the morgue trucks.
They're not going to do a memorial for the
people that died there holding a mass burning.
And this is an example of the type of stuff
I've talked to you about that takes likely
generations to fix.
There's no simple fix to this.
There's no specific intervention.
You can do that at a mass level will fix this
type of thinking and this type of programing.
It's being bred into the children at a young
age and it likely will take a generation to
make a dent.
And that's if we do everything perfectly.
That's if we reform education.
That's if we get people media literate enough
not to fall for the stuff that's on right
wing media.
It's it's an uphill battle.
And that's tragic and that's scary.
Let me know your thoughts.
We'll have more coverage of this delusional
mask burning on The David Pakman Show Instagram
page.
You can find us there at David Pakman show.
And you can find me on Instagram at David
Pakman as well.